remember this huge fuss about tiny  traces of benzene and sunscreens well  some researchers decided to go through  some old data where they asked people  about their sunscreen habits and  measured the benzene in their blood and  they found that people who use sunscreen  were less likely to have high levels of  benzene in their blood than people who  never use sunscreen this isn't that  surprising because the amount of benzene  you get from using sunscreen in the  worst case scenario is still pretty  insignificant less than half the amount  you breathe in a day in the city benzene  doesn't get through skin that easily and  so that means a lot of other factors  become more important like whether or  not you park your car in a garage  attached to your house so stay calm when  you see sunscreen scare stories in the  news sunscreens are some of the most  intensely scrutinized products we use